I am going to show you an unreal video
of sweaty Donald Trump losing it in a
free spree speech crushing video
we said before where's the policy the
Republicans have abandoned policy well
in this video
posted to truth social truth Central and
Rumble truth essential yeah
Donald Trump is announcing what sounds
like policy if indeed he were to again
become president of the United States
and it is chilling look at this
if we don't have free speech then we
just don't have a free country it's as
simple as that if this most fundamental
right is allowed to perish then the rest
of our rights and Liberties will topple
just like dominoes one by one they'll go
down that's why today I'm announcing my
plan to shatter the left-wing censorship
regime and to reclaim the right to free
speech for all Americans and reclaim is
a very important word in this case
because they've taken it away who recent
weeks bombshell reports have confirmed
that a Sinister group of deep State
bureaucrats Silicon Valley tyrants
left-wing activists and depraved
corporate news media have been
conspiring to manipulate and silence the
American people understand that that is
not an accurate representation of the
Twitter files we have done numerous deep
Dives now into the Twitter files no no
crimes were committed Twitter's own
terms of service were not violated and
Trump's White House had the same access
to individuals at Twitter then did the
Biden campaign
they have collaborated to suppress Vital
Information on everything from elections
to Public Health the censorship cartel
must be dismantled and destroyed and it
must happen immediately and here's my
plan here we go first within hours of my
inauguration I will sign an executive
order Banning any federal department or
agency from colluding with any
organization business or person to
censor limit categorize or impede the
lawful speech of American citizens now
remember what's funny about that is
it was the Biden campaign who would ask
Twitter to remove pictures of Hunter
Biden nude Trump is talking about
government actors
his administration was the one empowered
to do that in the time described by the
Twitter files Trump is really talking
about himself here it's stunning I will
then ban Federal money from being used
to label domestic speech as miss or
disinformation and I will begin the
process of identifying and firing every
Federal bureaucrat who has engaged in
domestic censorship directly or
indirectly whether they are the
Department of Homeland Security by the
way I don't know if you noticed that cut
this is clearly based on how much Trump
is sweating and slurring the type of
video he needed a hundred takes to get
completed the Department of Health Human
Services the FBI the doj no matter who
they are second I will order the
Department of Justice the these cuts are
just unbelievable just to investigate
all parties involved in the new online
censorship regime which is absolutely
destructive and terrible and to
aggressively prosecute any and all
crimes identified these include possible
violations of federal civil rights law
campaign Finance laws federal election
law now I just again to try to inject
some reality here as an example
they have these the Maga people
have been trying to make the case
that when Twitter acted on removing nude
images of Hunter Biden which are illegal
in Most states and violate Twitter's
terms of service that that helped the
Biden campaign therefore they argue it
has monetary value it was not disclosed
as being of monetary value as a campaign
contribution thus
it was a crime
no serious legal expert is buying even a
crumb of that insane hypothesis
Securities Law and Anti-Trust laws the
Hatch Act and a host of other potential
criminal civil Regulatory and
constitutional offenses to assist in
these efforts I am urging House
Republicans to immediately send
preservation letters and we have to do
this right now to the Biden
Administration the Biden campaign and
every Silicon Valley Tech Giant ordering
them not to destroy evidence of
censorship start upon my inauguration as
president I will ask Congress to send a
bill to my desk revising section 230
yeah to get big online platforms out of
censorship business from now on digital
platforms should only qualify for
immunity protection under Section 230 if
they meet High stand hundreds of
neutrality transparency fairness and
non-discrimination this is Bonkers I
mean this is just unreal it's Trump not
understanding anything claiming he's
going to do things he can't do and won't
do and hopefully will not even get the
opportunity to do we should require
these platforms
down on law
on locha's
exploitation and promoting terrorism
while dramatically curtailing their
power
to arbitrarily restrict lawful speech
fourth we need to break up the entire
toxic censorship industry that has
arisen under the false guys of tackling
so-called to miss this the the sad thing
about this is that this is such
meaningless dribble that his followers
think is just God's gift to statements
by candidates and disinformation the
federal government should immediately
stop funding all non-profits and
academic programs all right you get the
picture this is extremely Free Speech
crushing he wants to tell social media
platforms what they have to publish it's
not sounding very much small government
is it if Trump were to get another term
I assure you he would try to do these
things he would probably fail but it's
better not to even give him that
opportunity absolutely deranged stuff
unreal one of our sponsors today is blue
chew a unique online service delivering
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping